[Music]
[Applause]
spring
albert breer senior nfl reporter lead
content strategist for the monday
morning quarterback
do want to let you know albert that you
are live on the show right now
thanks for the heads up okay i
appreciate it just want to let you so
everything's nice and legal here yes
it is yes it is i think most members of
the media
don't really care about sort of these
details behind the scenes did julio
jones know he was on the air not
fans don't care they just want to know
well where is he going to go here
so let me at least touch on what
happened here with julio jones and
shannon sharp do you think julio knew he
was on the air live
i don't think he knew um you know just
digging around a little bit yesterday i
i really got the sense based on the way
some things went down that that he
didn't know
and honestly i mean without having
inside knowledge of exactly the way that
that went down between shannon and julio
like we have 10 years of track record on
julio dan i mean
like does that seem a little out of
character like
he is such a private guy and
like the fact that they were able to
keep this quiet for two and a half
months
like i like why would you just blurt
that out
like it's just like the whole thing
smelled funny
when it happened and the more i dig
around the more it's sort of
it just seems to have confirmed the fact
that that he didn't
fully know that he was what he was
saying was going out to a national
television audience and i think if you
listen to the conversation it sounds
like casual conversation
between a couple guys on the phone i
think we heard about
there were whispers around the draft
that julio jones could be traded i think
the night of the draft we thought that
maybe there's a chance that he could be
traded
but now you fast forward this to go okay
if you're the falcons i view this as a
matthew stafford moment like hey we're
open for business
he wants out and if you want to make us
an offer
we're not the bad guys moving on from
julio jones
but i also go back to their draft
strategy here
if if you're letting julio go you're
bringing in kyle pitch but you still
have matt ryan
that's where i wondered why not just do
a total reset
and i know you still have matt ryan for
a year uh
at least but you could have drafted the
quarterback so there's a lot to kind of
unpack here because i think that they
feel like they're close enough where
they can compete right now with the core
players they have even absent julio
and if you look like i mean dion jones
really good middle linebacker jake
matthews really good left tackle calvin
ridley potentially a number one receiver
they've poured a lot of first round
picks into that offensive line
um yeah i think you can see where the
new guy's in charge there the gm terry
fontenot and the coach
arthur smith feel like we can win right
now
and we can do maybe what andy reid did
in kansas city where
we can build around a veteran
quarterback for the first few years
be competitive year in and year out and
then eventually pick our spot when
there's a quarterback out there that we
really like in the draft
and get aggressive and go and get them
but i do think job number one for them
going into this off season was cleaning
up the salary cap and that's
how this whole thing began they really
have five players that got gigantic
contracts on their roster
um and that's you know ryan julio dion
jones
jake matthews and grady jarrett and
they've already restructured three of
those guys so
you know ryan dion jones and jake
matthews are in for 2021.
the question then becomes where do you
find space going forward do you want to
keep pushing money forward so
what's already going to be a 20 22
problem becomes a 2023 problem
and i just think when you add the fact
that julio
quietly lodged that request through his
agent
um in early march you can kind of add
things up where you say okay
the falcons we're looking for cap relief
here's a guy who doesn't want out
the other guys want in let's build going
forward as if we're going to win right
now knowing
that there's one big big piece of the
puzzle that's probably going to come out
who should call the falcons today i
like doesn't it make all the sense in
the world that this could be the olive
branch to aaron rodgers
like i mean it's just and their cap is
an issue and everything else but
like if like here's the thing with the
packers and aaron like
i think they're in a little bit of a
tough spot because like a lot of this
and i think we talked about this last
week
goes back to last year the communication
of the jordan love
pick was poor between the team and
rogers that created hard feelings
i think the fact that the packers have
largely stood pat
as far as veteran acquisitions this off
season rubbed him the wrong way he wants
them to build
the way that the bucks have built around
brady well if you really want aaron back
in
you know you figure it's tough to prove
to him that you're going to build a
different way at this juncture in the
off season
and now that opportunity is sitting
there for you right now
maybe you mortgage a couple contracts
you do some things that you haven't done
in the past
to bring in a star player and give aaron
rodgers julio jones to play opposite
devante adams
like it just to me like if you if you're
the packers and you
really really want aaron rodgers back in
and you feel like you're in a two or
three year window
to compete for championships what better
olive brands than to to get aaron
rodgers back in than to go acquire julio
jones how about this you trade jordan
love for julio jones
that's perfect right and then the
falcons and then the falcons have a guy
they can develop on their roster
right i mean like now all of a sudden
this was interesting
albert we saw we solved this this is we
just solved two major problems julio
jones is a packer aaron rodgers is back
in
the falcons have their quarterback in
the future we just talked for five
minutes
and solved everything that we just
talked about in 20 seconds that was easy
that was easy uh what was the big
takeaway from aaron rodgers interview
last night uh that you have to decode
everything which i think you know you
know aaron well enough dan that you have
to decode everything that he says and
i think when he says it's about the
people you know he's pointing back to
the communication issues that there have
been over the last year and a half and
you know again and i hate to keep
harping on it i don't think it's
as much about the jordan love pick
itself as it is
the way it happened how it caught him
off guard how he found out about it
while they're on the clock
i just think that could have been
handled better and i think there are
people in the packers
organization that would concede that to
you um you know and then
i i think going forward you know now is
radar's up and
it's okay well how are you gonna show me
that this is about maximizing my window
and the fact that again they stood pat
from a veteran acquisition standpoint
over the course of the last three or
four months i'm sure rubs him the wrong
way
and so you know i i think it's just it's
two trains on different tracks right now
and it's how you kind of bring those
two together to get everybody kind of
pointing in the same direction
the packers have built a certain way for
30 years and they're principled about it
and it's worked for them they've been a
consistent contender over three decades
and you have a quarterback now that's
you know looking at himself and saying
i'm on a two or
three year timetable and i want to go
compete for championships right now
right now and oh by the way that team
down in tampa
is building much more aggressively than
my team is and that's what i'm going to
be up against in the nfc over the next
couple of years
and so i think so much of this boils
down to whether or not the packers
are willing to change the way they've
done business for the last 30 years
which is a
very very difficult thing for any
organization to consider what would you
have asked aaron last night
i would have asked him more direct
questions about the
team president and the general manager i
don't think the issue was ever
matt lafleur and listen i understand
this is this is kenny maine's farewell
show and he can handle it any way he
wants so i'm not being critical of kenny
in any way
um but i i do think that crux of the
issue here is
um you know like the way that the front
office has handled things and and really
you know if you want to you know point
to the two guys that swing the biggest
sticks
um in the front office it's the team
president mark murphy and the general
manager brian gudykoon so
i think once you got past him saying i
don't have a problem with the coaching
staff i don't have a problem
um with jordan i don't have a problem
with x y and z
i would have said well do you have a
problem with the front office i think
that the answer to that question would
have been really interesting yeah that's
what i keep wondering okay so this is
the problem
how do we fix the problem and that's
what i would want to know
he you know he cites curly neal and
lombardi and
farve and bardstar and the people and
the teammates
why would you give that up because of
one or two people
like that doesn't make any sense you
don't play with them you may
see them you don't have to talk to them
i didn't like members of management at
espn
but i love the people i work with i
would hate to
go oh i'm just going to give all of this
up because i don't like this person
and that's what i wonder this is the
best place for aaron rodgers to win
so we're presuming though that his end
game is to be out of green bay
i think he's staying here like like but
here's what i'm saying like
like the presumption when people hear
trade requests right
the presumption is always well the guy
just wants to be out of there
when i don't think that's always the
truth like i think sometimes these
things happen
as leverage plays and i like there's a
big part of me dan that thinks
like he likes the offense he's playing
and he loves devonta smith we know his
close relationship with his left tackle
david back to yari
in a lot of ways green bay is much
better than the teams we've heard
um could be interested in trading for
him right much better spot for him and
he can cement his legacy forever there
yeah so what if denver is going to have
to give up first round
why would he want to go to denver yeah
and that's the thing
that that's the question i'm asking so
what if the end game here
isn't so much i want out it's i want you
to change the way
you're doing business and if it takes me
threatening to leave me threatening not
to show up
i'm going to push every button that i
possibly can push
to try to get the you to change the way
that you do business
so over the next two or three years i
have the best shot
to win a championship and let's hey
let's let's let's let's play this
hypothetical out
was it worth it going through through
all of this if it means julio jones in
two weeks
yeah right like yeah so if it was a
leverage play
and it and it and it gets the packers to
move off their spot
and go get julio jones and again you
didn't have to move around a lot of
things to make that happen you know like
they'd have to move
they'd have to they'd have to like like
do a lot of what tampa's done quite
frankly
to to get julio jones in but
i mean you would be adding a top-shelf
weapon who's on the same timetable as
aaron rodgers doesn't have a ton of time
left right and julio would be coming
into an offense
he's familiar with because the head
coach in green bay
matt lafleur was the quarterbacks coach
in atlanta
when julio went to the super bowl so i
just think in a lot of different ways
like
you know if you look at what aaron
rodgers is trying to do here
i mean maybe he wants out under the
current circumstances but maybe his
ideal is
that i want to change my circumstances
here and if it takes me
threatening leaving to change those
circumstances then i'm willing to do
that
by the way my sneaky mvp this year
you want to guess justin herbert no
sneakier than that
joe burrow not that sneaky
[Laughter]
matthew stafford i like it yeah i like
it
hey hey look what was jared goff before
sean mcvay got his hands on him
i mean jared goff looked like a train
wreck in year one and sean mcveigh
turned him around right away so
i mean stafford's a good quarterback to
begin with i think it makes sense
yeah absolutely that yeah
by the way what level of sunburn do you
have one to ten
i think it's the lights actually but i
don't have a sum i
i just tan really well it's a it's a
strength of mine dan
well the shirt i think also kind of adds
a little bit more of a
that's a fair yeah i think i've got a
little too much shine like
this light over here i moved it i it got
moved by my kids it got just kind of
like moved off a little bit
and so it's hitting my head in a certain
way where i've got like some shine going
there so
i'm not sunburnt right now but i do tan
really well so
and you'll be able to see that over the
next few months and i look forward to
that
yeah i look forward to seeing your ten
ask eisen eisen will tell you how well i
tell you i i want to see your tan lines
that's really what i want to see
yeah right now yeah shirt right now i'm
here huh
yes uh you're gonna be officially off
the air now
okay okay okay so i can say whatever i
want then once you
so so in 30 seconds when todd talks to
me like right now
right now we're we're just a couple of
guys talking
okay no don't say anything because then
you're gonna rip
like jason lochenfora or you're gonna
rip you know uh
chef d so i don't want you doing i'm
gonna say i want out going to say that
just of that room you went out of that
room right now because the lights are
too shiny
uh albert thank you as always all right
great thanks dan
albert breer senior uh nfl reporter and
lead strategist for the monday morning
quarterback